Hey, David.
It seems as though it is red states rather
than blue states opening early from Corona
virus and Republicans rather than Democrats
who ignore social distancing and mask wearing.
Is it possible that Corona virus could hand
the election to Biden by killing more Republicans
than Democrats?
OK, I understand the argument.
I understand the argument.
If you've got a state like Michigan, for example,
we'll just pick Michigan.
And the Democratic voters are mostly following
the guidelines and the Republican voters are
not.
Aren't you going to get more Republican voters
infected with the virus and thus more Republican
voters will die?
And it could flip Michigan from Trump in 2016
to Biden in 2020.
So, first of all, disclaimer, I hope it's
not necessary.
I don't want anybody to die.
I'm not hoping anyone dies.
Democrats, Republicans.
It's a question about math, really.
Not a question about anything else.
I don't believe the deaths are numerous, nearly
numerous at this point.
For this to actually affect the outcome in
any state.
Let's look at an example.
I mentioned Michigan.
In 2016, Trump won Michigan by about 11000
votes.
Right now, Michigan has had 50, 500 corona
virus deaths.
Even if we imagine, which I'm sure is not
the case.
Imagine that a full 80 percent of the people
who died in Michigan are Trump voters.
It's still not enough to flip an 11000 vote
margin.
And that's a state where the margin was really,
really small.
Now, if Michigan ends up with 50000 deaths
and 80 or 85 percent of them were Trump fists,
you might have enough to flip the state from
Trump to Biden.
The reality is it's unlikely Michigan is going
to get 10 x the deaths we've seen so far by
Election Day.
And I think the most important thing here
and again, I don't want anybody to die.
No one else has to die for us to realize Trump
failed the son corona virus.
In other words, if you believe that Corona
virus will affect how people vote, you shouldn't
need anymore deaths.
You shouldn't need anybody else to die from
the virus, either for political or mathematical
reasons, as we're talking about for us.
No, Trump's biggest test so far has been corona
virus, and he's failed.
He's being tested on the civil unrest.
He's also failing there.
We shouldn't need anyone else to die to be
able to say he failed us and he needs to go.
Last thing on this corona virus is also disproportionately
affecting poor people and communities of color.
Those are communities that disproportionately
vote for Democrats over Republicans.
So the older folks, the which is a group that
has been better for Trump and for Republicans.
They're, of course, the most at risk from
an age perspective.
But you also have communities of color and
poor communities that are disproportionately
affected.
Those are not communities that are likely
to go to Trump.
So I would even challenge the assertion that
that we started with, which is that it is
simply going to be split primarily among party
lines based on following or not following
social distancing guidelines.
In the end, one hundred and thirty million
people voted in 2016 just to to affect one
percent of the electorate.
You need one point three million Corona virus
deaths.
We are nowhere close to that.
I hope we are never anywhere close to that.
And certainly there's no indication we would
be anywhere near that in November.
So it is unlikely, unlikely that the WHO dies
from Corona virus would be enough to flip
even a single state, even a state that was
really close in 2016 by enough votes to change
the outcome.
You disagree with me?
Let me know.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
join Pacman dot com or by becoming a patron
at patry on dot com slash David Pakman show.